So now that you've learned about
monetization models, there are just
a few more steps to finalize your game
and help it stand out in the crowd.
>> We've also learned about
building an engaging game.
But it's important to ask
players what they think.
This lesson will cover
how to use analytics and
testing tools to get helpful feedback.
And once you've tested out your game,
you'll want to get it
noticed in an app store.
There are a lot of games out there.
And if no one has heard of your game,
how can you encourage
people to download it?
>> When people are discovering a game,
they look for exciting visuals and
a clear description We'll talk
in depth about design strategies
that can increase your game's
visibility in the app store.
>> And finally, we'll will show you how
to deploy your app to an app store.
So after this lesson, you'll be
ready to publish your own game.